many came together to raise funds for
the family of a father and son
killed in a wrong way crash our team has
been covering this story since it
happened in late may on the u.s 95 near
rancho
reporter kate houston joins us live in
the newsroom with more on the efforts to
help this family left behind
kate yes sasha it's been a little over
two weeks now since the robledos lost
two beloved members of their family they
tell me they're heartbroken
but they're so grateful for the support
that they've received so far
and that support continued today with a
community car wash hosted by the los
villanos booster club
the president of the club tells me they
wanted to help because this tragedy
could have happened to anybody
around a dozen people came out to scrub
down some cars and take donations
those will go directly to the families
of porfirio and rodolfo robledo
eloisa the mother and wife of the
victims say they're still in shock
my husband was dedicated to work to his
sons
he had a lot of dreams to see more
family like my daughter
and his grandkids my son was a very hard
working man
he was very responsible and is leaving
behind his four kids and wife
who are in mexico police say the driver
who hit the robleros was impaired
eloise is now asking the community to be
aware of their actions
saying innocent people are paying the
price the money raised at today's
fundraiser will go to the family
and will help cover funeral expenses
donations are also being taken through
zell and a gofundme all of that
information can be found on our website
8newsnow.com
back to you sasha